c'est la nuit de dimanche à l'urgence
est une menace qui semble avoir porté
fruit devant la possibilité de refus de
faire des heures supplémentaires
obligatoires en fin de semaine les
établissements de santé concernés ont
mis les bouchées doubles hier soir il y
avait très peu de
cas supplémentaires
à l'achat dans les 10 6 us et 6 ainsi
qu'aux chutes québec le fameux ts aux
abbesses et radicalement le
sélectionneur
le cius de la capitale nationale et de
la mauricie centre du québec ont
mobilisé leurs cadres pour pallier la
pénurie de personnel la question est
sérieuse le ts au fait fuir les
infirmières si on impose un temps
supplémentaire obligatoire si la
situation s'améliore pas je suis prête à
quitter le réseau c'est décidé c'est
pourquoi la fiq est en guerre ouverte
contre le ps aux mises en demeure
envoyée au gouvernement aux pdg des
établissements fautifs et même aux
ordres professionnels elle demande
l'aide de la cnss thé et de la
commission des droits de la personne le
ministre christian dubé veut lui aussi
enrayer cette pratique au sein des
établissements mais encore faut-il du
personnel je peux vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui j'en veux plus haut c'est
que tant qu'on n'a pas assez de monde
pour couvrir tous les quart de travail
on n'a pas le job d'utiliser ces
mécanismes qui sont très négatifs
le gamin est capable
escudé s'est d'hydro-québec des casinos
qui prend pour le monde
il manque plus de 5500 infirmières et
infirmières auxiliaires à temps complet
dans le réseau sans compter celles non
vaccinés qui seront suspendus à la mi
novembre en mettant en demeure le mythe
de la santé assurant la quête un moment
très stratégique et très précis au va
avoir besoin de nos travers la santé
pour s'assurer d'avoir une qualité et
une sécurité des soins optimale la fiq
mais le bain se met dans une position un
peu maladroite la fiq donne jusqu'au 15
novembre au gouvernement pour mettre fin
aux heures supplémentaires obligatoires
cet ultimatum coïncide avec la nouvelle
date de suspension des employés non
vacciné sans ses employés et santé est
ce le réseau pourrait faire face à de
nombreux bris de service ici marie josée
paquet comme radio canada montréal